what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things youtube channel
today um i'm gonna be talking about a
complaint that i got from my last video
um or maybe it was two videos ago i
don't even know but
i posted a video talking about some
advice that my dad
who gave me my dad who's like very
successful and
a lot of people were saying that i
shouldn't be able to give that advice
because it's not fair
from me being like where i come from
like i have a super successful father
and here's the here's the funny thing um
the advice this is the advice right my
dad has always told me from a young age
chase um do what you're good at and do
what you're interested in so he's
always said to
do what you're interested in do what
you're good at and the money will come
and chase skills not money so he's he's
told me to take a lower paying job
if you're gonna build skills like better
does that make sense okay
and the funny thing is i got so many
comments saying
you know that's not statistically true
that's not the case for everyone
and here's the funny thing i feel
as though oh my gosh you guys hate i
feel so i'm doing you guys a favor
by giving you guys for free the advice
that my dad has given me over the years
my dad is the wisest
smartest person that i know i've never
met anyone
that has lived like a more pure life my
dad doesn't drink
he doesn't smoke he doesn't go out to
bars
like he married one woman at a young age
had 10 kids with her and he doesn't even
do
social media like he doesn't even chase
that validation like my dad is so
freaking cool
and what i do is i give you guys tidbits
of advice that have helped me and help
me and my siblings
all of which have grown up i mean some
of my like some of my siblings are still
like my younger sisters
14 but all of us have grown up to like
not be crackheads and not be like
anything crazy you know um like
i guarantee pretty much all of us will
graduate college and if anyone doesn't
graduate college it's probably
because they're starting a business we
have every advantage in the world that's
100 true but my parents they didn't
neither of them came for money
like it's all stuff they've built so if
you guys don't if you guys want to shoot
the messenger
and say that this advice is bad because
i'm the one telling you
that's totally fine you don't have to
listen but it's good advice
and if you don't want to listen that's
totally fine it's your loss
anyways to the real subscribers and
supporters who appreciate the advice
that i give you on this channel
um some of which comes from my dad leave
a comment let me know
um you can let me know either way i
don't care help so i'll grow them but i
will talk to you guys
next time